une vision d'horreur le 13 juillet
dernier au petit matin anthony chan va
retrouve trois de ces bêtes mortes après
une attaque de chien pour ce jeune
chevrier reconverti depuis trois ans
dans l'élevage caprin biologique
les conséquences de cette attaque sont à
leur désastreuse semaine d'après il y
avait deux chèvres qui avait avorté
donc bon déjà voilà de chèvre de morte
deux chefs qui portait ça commençait
déjà à mettre la faire enfin le choix
tation un péril sérieusement quoi et la
demande et une échographie de contrôle
qui ont été refaites trois semaines
après et là gros dégâts on se sert
d'avoir tu es sur nous et donc une perte
sèche total et là bas de revenus l'hiver
on peut moyens de payer des emprunts si
on ne paye pas les emprunts il faut
arrêter donc ça me faisait cinquante
mille euros d'emprunt remboursait ça me
faisait vingt mille euros de dégâts en
bourse dont le village
un groupe de soutien se met rapidement
en place pour lui venir en aide
une campagne de financement participatif
est alors créé une personne du village
mireille qui a proposé de voir sur un
site participatif
donc c'est ce qui a été fait on a vu un
peu ce qu'on allait mettre sur ce site
avec anthony mireille et moi on est
allés ensemble et voilà le site à
fonctionner parfaitement et j'en suis
très heureuse pour lui parce que ça lui
permet de continuer son activité
cette campagne a permis à anthony de
récolter au total près de 4000 euros de
dons et de recevoir de nombreux
courriers de soutien
grâce à cette cagnotte le jeune
agriculteur a déjà pu racheter une
douzaine de chèvres dès cet hiver il va
pouvoir assurer sa production laitière
pour faire face à ces charges ont bien
secoués parce que l'accident s'était
déjà choquant mais de voir que les gens
sont
sont débrouillés pour nous filer un coup
de main c'est quand même une belle
histoire aujourd'hui devoir faire c'est
parti d'un accident compliqué finalement
une très très belle histoire
grâce à cet élan de solidarité anthony
peut désormais repartir de l'avant
il devrait reprendre une activité
normale dès la fin du mois de septembre